it's come out that the national enquirer
paid president Trump's doorman $30,000
so they could kill a story about Trump
yeah was that it's not shocking a Trump
employee actually got paid I'm winning
this guy over he kind of he was like all
right that was pretty good all right I
had to work on this woman with the
jacket that guy this is true it's a
crazy story the National Enquirer paid
$30,000 for a story about President
Trump having a love child but then they
buried the story yeah Enquirer said we
did it
to protect the child from finding out
his father is Donald
the Navy is in the news the Navy is
calling for new weapons so they can
fight much more effectively against
Russia yes yeah the number one weapon
they're asking for is a different
president next time don't make that
sound until you've heard the jokes I got
some good news from Alaska I want some
good news from Alaska I love Alaska news
yeah
he says that every night the city of
Anchorage Alaska has voted down a
bathroom bill that discriminates against
transgendered people yeah good for that
yeah residents said you know it's so
cold here in Alaska we can't tell what
genitals you have anyway Starbucks
Starbucks is opening its first store in
Uruguay yeah actually these Starbucks
was supposed to open in Uganda but a
barista signed the paperwork come on
come on let me have that one yeah one of
the world's top Donkey Kong players has
been stripped of his Records for
cheating yeah he was gonna be sentenced
to life but it turns out he doesn't have
one
let's shake hands shake hands that this
means shake hands
you try those out somewhere see how easy
it is but tell me where you're doing it
so I can sit there and go
you
you